Speaker 1: Peter Navarro has been indicted
by a federal grand jury on criminal contempt
of Congress charges for his refusal to
cooperate in the January 6th investigation.
Navarro lost it and Trump lost it
as a result. Now, as a reminder,
Peter Navarro was an economic adviser to Trump
completely unhinged, complete 2020 big lie
conspiracy guy. He was called in by the
January six committee, refused to testify.
And he is being held in criminal contempt. He
was arrested. He was cuffed. He was booked.
Now, Jamie Raskin told us they were going to try
to do this. When I interviewed Congressman Jamie
Raskin last week, who's on that committee. He
said, we are attempting to hold in contempt the
people who have refused to testify. He didn't
mention Peter Navarro by name. And now here is
Peter Navarro flipping out at how he was treated.
Speaker 4: Instead of coming to my door
where I live, which, by the way, is right
next to the FBI, stand and call me and say,
hey, we need you down at court. We got a warrant
for you. I would gladly come. What did they do?
They intercepted me getting on the plane,
and then they put me in handcuffs right here.
They put me in leg irons. They stick me in itself,
by the way. Just historical note. I was in John
Hinckley cell. Wow. Think that that was big
time? No. Okay. That's punitive. That that what
they did to me today violated the Constitution.
Speaker 1: So he doesn't like it. And he's very,
very upset. The January 6th committee, Twitter
published a message about this saying, quote,
While today's indictment of Peter Navarro was
the correct decision by the Justice Department,
we find the decision to reward Mark Meadows and
Dan Scavino for their continued attack on the rule
of law. Puzzling. They have also refused to show
up and have now, as of now, not yet been arrested.
Now, Trump lost it on his platform. Truth, social
truth central. Donald Trump publishing a message
saying, wow. Peter Navarro, our brilliant, Harvard
educated White House trade official, by the way,
the Harvard thing, when they want to attack
people who went to Harvard, they go liberal,
indoctrinating woakes. They're Harvard. Well,
Harvard's bad. But then when they want to say,
Hey, why would they arrest one of our guys
and treat him like this? They go he went.
Speaker 5: To Harvard.
Speaker 1: After all. And
you're still treating him like this story for a
different day. Wow. Peter Navarro, our brilliant,
Harvard educated White House trade official, who
was by far the toughest advocate for tariffs,
taxes and powerful right powerful regulations
on China, was just handcuffed, shackled and put
into prison because he didn't obey the orders
of the UN Select Committee of Political Thugs,
many of whom are involved with impeachment.
Hoax number one, impeachment hoax number two,
the Mueller report scam and of course, the
now fully debunked Russia, Russia, Russia
con they've gone crazy. So Trump losing it.
Everybody losing it. Listen, you got to show
up. That's it. It you just you've got to show
up. They were told we will hold you in contempt.
They are doing it at least to some people.
And we will see what happens next as far as
Peter Navarro is concerned. But what Jamie Raskin
told us they were going to do, they're doing and
every single one of these people needs to be held
accountable. Hopefully, this is the start of that.